and it's all guys was so full you guys
tore anything for new patients
yep but aren't true that um yeah we do
something for new patients new patient
now innovation how many patients can't
get any more than this what do you want
um where's your license man for sure
yeah I'm having pockets in this thing is
like I might have left it in the
hospital
what's your name I'll look you up my
name is me patient I mean I'm like Huck
like hot Mike Hawk Mike Hawk Mike Hawk
my car I'll be right back no isn't for
um people who wear regular clothes for
here man we got some Ebola sativa right
here just for you oh oh yeah you bet hey
man you guys are really good at your job
yeah man this war gets goin man to spare
let's go yeah it's just cool it's cool
man don't try that [ __ ] again bro what's
up dude worded my Copco of denote my cog
was that sketchy dude that was in here
the other day on it you have made such a
dick can I help you
Oh